as the u.s. prepares for the arrival of
hurricane durian we're seeing the full
extent of the destruction left behind in
the northern Bahamas
the nonprofit world's central kitchen
led by renowned chef Jose Andres is one
of the aid groups spearheading relief
efforts our lead national correspondent
David beg no spoke to him in Nassau
just last night David this is a massive
operation how is it being carried out
behind me is a Coast Guard helicopter
that landed a short time ago that just
means it was nearly 11 o'clock last
night when chef Jose Andres invited us
into his war room where he was intensely
planning an urgent mass feeding
operation it needs to be very quick
today he and his team of about a dozen
people from the non-governmental
organization world central kitchen are
aiming to deliver 30,000 meals a day to
the Abaco Islands and to Grand Bahama
they have felt the brunt of Dorian's
wrath the damage is widespread UN
officials say more than 60,000 people on
the islands will need food the Red Cross
says 62 thousand people need clean
drinking water in the northern part of
the Abaco Islands everything is gone if
not addressed the team has been working
non-stop prepping and delivering meals
to those who have been impacted by the
hurricane
on Monday the chef went to the Abaco
Islands and he brought with him more
than a thousand ham and cheese
sandwiches we're an NGO that we're
trying to be saving as many lives we can
one meal at the time to carry out this
massive operation the chef is chartered
to see planes and an amphibious vehicle
he says he's also rented at least two
helicopters that will be used to ferry
food from this boat that he hired that's
coming from Florida
but they big news this is not the first
time the celebrity chef has become a
disaster first responder after Hurricane
Maria devastated Puerto Rico world
central kitchen stepped in to serve
nearly four million meals with the help
of thousands of volunteers obviously
number one priority right now is we are
trying to search and rescue search and
rescue Andre says the goal here in the
Bahamas is to give the local government
less problems to solve that's what we're
trying to do to create the system of
feeding so this problem goes away and
they can take care of everything else
you are looking live at a United States
Coast Guard helicopter that is preparing
to take off it is loaded with members of
the Bahamian National Guard I talked to
one of the commanders who said the Coast
Guard is taking these Guardsmen to the
Abaco Islands I said what is their
mission is it security and she said as
she walked away rescue rescue rescue
rescue they are still in a rescue mode
right now as it pertains to the chef
it's incredible to see the resources
that he himself has brought in in order
to distribute the food he said David I
can't be tying up resources like the US
Coast Guard are begging other people who
need to actually get in and rescue folks
I need to bring in my own resources
that's why he's hired those ships and
boats and helicopters he said another
thing Tony that I'll never forget he
said when you come into a disaster zone
like this you got to have empathy and a
will to just get it done
yeah ham and cheese sandwiches to
seaplanes an amphibious vehicle what is
he expecting to encounter once he's out
there
look I mean first of all just getting to
that area finding a place to land as a
challenge but I remember last night and
that meeting that we were in Tony was so
intense right with his people at the
table and at one point he said listen
don't give me any of that fancy food we
send to restaurants that are that are
watered down or something this is not a
fancy restaurant give me the hearty
stuff that I can feed people who may not
eat another meal for two or three days
after we encountered them yeah make the
rescue and then have the good the good
stuff for the celebration David beg no
forests in the Bahamas David thank you
very much